- Le moment est solennel,uxuxux.
Pour la deuxième fois
en moins d'un mois,
Joe Biden joue le rôle
du consolateur en chefdededededl
à cause de la violence armée.
"F"Faites quelque chose!",
crie l'un des badauds.
"Nous allons faire quelque
dont le pouvoir de changer les
lois en la matière e s somme
toute assez limité.
La visite de Jod Biden est bien
malgré tout que les lois
sur le contrôle des armes
à feu soient renforcées.
"Il faut relever l'âge minimum
de 18 à 21 ans, explique Monica
Gutierrez, pour acheter
de
"Vous pouvez acheter ces armes
chez Wal-Mart, dit Veronica
Autant de propositions qui sont
sur la tab
pour interdire ces armes
d'assautcococomme cela a déjà
été le cas pendant 10 ans
jusq
ouvertures dans les négociations
avec les républicains.
Ce représentant républicain
à l'interdiction
des armes d'assaut.
dit-il, mais ils ont peur
de le dire ou même de voter
en faveur de projets de lois,
de leur parti.
Robert Garza en a assez
des tergiversations aiaiaiaiaia.
Les démocrates ne veulent pas
priver les Américains du droit
veulent juste que des vies
ne soient chchchchchées par
ces armes à feu. En attendant,
bien des questions demeurent
jamais dû arriver ici.
En plus des enquêtes internes de
l'État du Texas, le département
mener la sienne sur le
déroulement de l'intervention
policière de mardi dernier.
du propre aveu des autorités
locales, a été très mal gérée.
C'est une autre façon de passer
commises ici afin d'éviter
d'autres cafouillages dans
les inévitables futures
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, Uvalde au Texas